[Music]
sitting alone at night in secret study
it is placed on the brass tripod a
slight flame comes out of the emptiness
and makes successful that which should
not be believed in vain a wand in the
hand is placed in the middle of the
tripods legs with water he sprinkles
both the hem of his garment and his foot
a voice fear he trembles in his robes
divine splendor the God sits nearby when
the litters are overturned by the
whirlwind and faces are covered by
cloaks the New Republic will be troubled
by its people at this time the reds and
the whites will rule wrongly in the
world there will be made a king who will
have little peace and short life at this
time the shape of the papacy will be
lost
governed to its greatest detriment they
will be driven away for a long drawn-out
fight the countryside will be most
grievously troubled town and country
will have greater struggle Carcassonne
and now born will have their hearts tied
the eyes of ravana will be forsaken when
his wings will fall at his feet the two
of breasts say will have made a
constitution for Turan and Vercelli
which the french will trample underfoot
arrived too late the act has been done
the wind was against them letters
intercepted on their way the
conspirators of fourteen of a party by
Rousseau Shelley's enterprises be
undertaken how often will you be
captured Oh city of the Sun changing
laws that are barbaric and vain bad
times approach you no longer will you be
enslaved great hey dree will revive your
veins from the Orient will come the
African heart to trouble Hadrian the
heirs of Romulus accompanied by the
Libyan fleet the temples of Malta and
nearby islands shall be deserted
a coffin is put into the vault of iron
were seven children of the King held the
ancestors and forebears will come forth
from the depth of hell lamenting to see
thus dead the fruit of their line the
motion of senses heart feet and hands
will be an agreement between Naples
Leone and Sicily swords fire floods then
the noble Romans drowned killed all dead
because of a weak brain there will soon
be talk of a treacherous man who rules a
short time quickly raised from low to
high estate he will suddenly turn
disloyal and volatile this man will
govern Verona through anger and internal
hatreds the Exile will hatch a great
plot against the king secretly they will
place enemies as a threat and his own
adherents will find sedition against
them from the enslaved populace songs
chants and demands while princes and
Lords are held captive in prisons these
will in the future by headless idiots be
received as divine prayers Mars
threatens us with the force of war and
will cause blood to be spilt seventy
times the clergy will be both exalted
and reviled moreover by those who wish
to learn nothing of them a scythe joined
with a pond in sagittarius at its
highest ascent plague famine death from
military hands the century approaches
its renewal for 40 years the rainbow
will not be seen for 40 years it will be
seen every day the dry earth will grow
more parched and there will be great
floods when it is seen because of French
discord and negligence an opening shall
be given to the muhammadans the land and
sea of Siena will be soaked in blood and
the port of Marseilles covered with
ships and sails
when the snakes surrounded the altar and
the Trojan blood is troubled by the
Spanish because of them a great number
will be lessened the leader flees hidden
in the swampy marshes the cities of
Tours Olli are Bois and Cher RAM and nut
are troubled by sudden change tents will
be pitched by people of foreign tongues
rivers darts at Rennes shaking of land
and sea the rock holds in its depths
white clay which will come out to milk
white from a cleft needlessly troubled
people will not dare touch it
unaware that the fountain of the earth
is of clay a thing existing without any
census will cause its own end to happen
through artifice at our tongue shall on
long gray and the to sin there will be
great damage from hail and ice in the
third month at sunrise the boar and the
leopard meet on the battlefield the
fatigued leopard looks up to heaven and
sees an eagle playing around the Sun at
the new city he is thoughtful to condemn
the bird of prey offers himself to the
gods after victory he pardons his
captives at Cremona and Mantua great
hardships will be suffered the lost
thing is discovered hidden for many
centuries pasture will be celebrated
almost as a god-like figure this is when
the moon completes her great cycle but
by other rumors he shall be Dishonored
the great man will be struck down in the
day by a thunderbolt an evil deed
foretold by the bearer of a petition
according to the prediction another
falls at night time conflicted Ram
London and pestilence in Tuscany beneath
the oak tree of GN struck by lightning
the treasure is hidden not far from
there that which for many centuries had
been gathered when found a man will die
I pierced by a spring table rock will
fear the barbarian fleet for a time then
much later the Western fleet kathal
people possessions all will be quite
lost what a deadly combat in Taurus and
Libra when the fish the travels over
both land and sea is cast up onto the
shore by a great wave its shape foreign
smooth and frightful from the sea the
enemies
soon reach the walls because of the
storm at sea the foreign ship will
approach an unknown port notwithstanding
the signs of the palm branches
afterwards there is death and pillage
good advice comes too late
the wars in France will last so many
years beyond the reign of the Castillon
kings and uncertain victory will crown
three great ones the Eagle the [ __ ] the
moon the lion and the Sun in its house
the great empire will soon be exchanged
for a small place which soon will begin
to grow a small piece of tiny area in
the middle of which he will come to lay
down his scepter near a great bridge
near a spacious plain the great a lion
with the Imperial forces will cause a
falling outside the austere city through
fear the gates will be unlocked for him
the bird of prey flying to the left
before battle is joined with the French
he makes preparations some will regard
him as good other's bad or uncertain the
weaker party will regard him as a good
omen the young lion will overcome the
older one in a field of combat in single
fight he will pierce his eyes in their
golden cage to wounds in one then he
dies a cruel death too late the king
will repent that he did not put his
adversary to death but he will soon come
to agree to far greater things which
will cause all in his line to die
shortly before sunset battle is engaged
a great nation is uncertain overcome a
seaport makes no answer
the bridge and the grave both in foreign
places the Sun and the Eagle will appear
to the victor an empty answer assured to
the defeated neither bugle nor shouts
will stop the soldiers liberty and peace
if achieved in time through death at
night the last one will be strangled in
his bed because he became too involved
with the blond air elect the Empire
isn't saved and three men substituted
his foot to death with neither letter
nor package ready the false trumpet
concealing madness will cause Byzantium
to change its laws from Egypt they will
go forth a man who wants the edict
withdrawn changing money and standards
the city is besieged and assaulted by
night few have escaped a battle not far
from the sea a woman faints with joy at
the return of her son poison in the
folds of the hidden letters the tenth
day of the April Callens calculated in
Gothic fashion is revived again by
wicked people the fire is put out and
the diabolica gathering seek the bones
of the demon of Seles before the empire
changes a very wonderful event will take
place the field moved the pillar of
porphyry put in place changed on the
gnarled rock in a short time sacrifices
will be resumed those opposed will be
put to death like martyrs there will no
longer be monks habits or novices honey
shall we far more expensive than wax a
founder of sects much trouble for the
accuser a beast in the theatre prepares
the scene and plot the author ennobled
by acts of older times the world
is confused by schismatic sects a very
near och Lecter owner and a great fire
will fall from the sky for three nights
the cause will appear both stupefying
and marvelous
shortly afterwards there will be an
earthquake the speeches of Lake Lamarr
will become angered the days will drag
out in two weeks than months then years
then all will fail the authorities will
condemn their useless powers when twenty
years of the moon's reign have passed
another will take up his reign for seven
thousand years when the exhausted son
takes up his cycle then my prophecy and
threats will be accomplished long before
these happenings the people of the East
influenced by the moon in the Year 1700
will cause many to be carried away and
will almost subdue the northern area
from the three water signs will be born
a man who will celebrate Thursday as his
holiday his renowned praise rule and
power will grow on land and sea bringing
trouble to the East the head of Ares
Jupiter and Saturn eternal God what
changes then the bad times will return
again after a long century what turmoil
in France in Italy two evil influences
in conjunction in Scorpio the Great Lord
is murdered in his room a newly
appointed King persecutes the church the
lower parts of Europe and in the North
alas how we will see a great nation
sorely troubled and the holy law in
utter ruin Christianity governed
throughout by other laws when a new
source of gold and silver is discovered
two revolutions will be caused by the
evil scythe bearer making a change of
rain and centuries the mobile sign thus
moves into its house equal in favor to
both sides in the land with a climate
opposite to Babylon there will be a
great shedding of blood
heaven will seem unjust both on land and
sea and in the air sects famine kingdoms
plagues confusion sooner and later you
will see great changes made dreadful
horrors and vengeance for as the moon is
thus led by its angel the heavens draw
near to the balance the trumpet shakes
with great discord an agreement broken
lifting the face to heaven the bloody
mouth will swim with blood the face
anointed with milk and honey of eyes on
the ground through a slit in the belly a
creature will be born with two heads and
four arms it will survive for some few
years the day that alkali
celebrates his festivals for sauna
tieran and the ruler of Ferrara will
follow the exiles deported to the
islands at the advent of an even more
cruel King will be murdered two will be
burnt who are not sparing in their
speech an emperor will be born near
Italy who will cost the Empire very
dearly they will say when they see his
allies that he is less a prince than a
butcher
the wretched unfortunate Republic will
again be ruled by a new authority the
great amount of ill-will accumulated in
exile will make the Swiss break their
important agreement alas what a great
loss they will be to learning before the
cycle of the moon is completed fire
great floods by more ignorant rulers how
long the centuries until it is seen to
be restored pestilences extinguished the
world becomes smaller for a long time
the lands will be inhabited peacefully
people will travel safely through the
sky over land and seas then Wars will
start up again at night they will think
they have seen the Sun when they see the
half pig man noise screams battle scene
fought in the skies the brute beasts
will be heard to speak a child without
hands never so great a thunderbolt scene
the royal child wounded as a game of
tennis after well lightning strikes
joining together three trussed up in the
middle under the oaks he who then
carries the news after a short while
will stop to breathe vivy air torn aw ma
Ferro and Prada hail and storm will make
them grieve the great famine which I
sense approaching will often turn in
various areas then become worldwide it
will be so vast and long-lasting that
they will grab roots from the trees and
children from the breasts Oh - what a
dreadful and wretched torment our three
innocent people going to be delivered
poison suggested badly guarded betrayal
delivered up to horror by drunken
executioner's the great mountain seven
stadia round after peace war famine
flooding it will spread far drowning
great countries even antiquities and
they're mighty foundations rain famine
and war will not cease in
- great a faith will betray the monarch
those actions started in France will end
their secret sign for on to be sparing
the marine tower will be captured and
retaken three times by Spaniards
barbarians and Ligurian Marseille and I
are less by men of Pisa devastation fire
sword pillage of Avignon by the torinese
the inhabitants of Marseille completely
changed fleeing and pursued as far as
Leo now bomb Toulouse and goodbye
Bordeaux the killed and captive are
almost 1 million France shall be accused
of neglect by her five partners Tunis
algea stirred up by the Persians Leone
Seville and Barcelona having failed they
will not have the fleet occurs over the
Venetians
after arrest they will travel to Paris a
great help coming from around Antioch
the curly-haired King will strive
greatly for the Empire the brazen beard
will be roasted on a spit the tyrant of
Siena will occupy Savona having won the
fort he will restrain the marine fleet
two armies under the standard of ancona
the leader will examine them in fear the
man will be cooled by a barbaric name
that three sisters will receive from
destiny he will speak then to a great
people in words and deeds more than any
other man will have fame and renown a
promontory stands between two seas a man
who will die later by the bit of a horse
[Music]
neptune unfurls of lac salé for his man
the fleet major rotor and receiver to an
old leader will be born an idiot hair
week both in knowledge and in war the
leader of France is feared by his sister
battlefields divided conceded to the
soldiers as ass licked or gone Dom alch
and aegon are troubled by laws disputes
and monopolies Carcassonne bordeaux
Toulouse and Bayon will be ruined when
they wish to renew the massacre from the
6th bright celestial light it will come
to Thunder very strongly in Burgundy
then a monster will be born of a very
hideous Beast in March April May and
June great wounding and worrying 9 will
be set apart from the human flock
separated from judgment and advice the
fate is to be divided as they depart k
the L dead banished and scattered when
the great wooden columns tremble in the
Southwind covered with blood such a
great assembly then pours forth that
Vienna and the land of Austria will
tremble the Alien Nation will divide the
spoils Saturn in dreadful aspect in Mars
dreadful and foreign to the Tuscans and
Latins Greeks who will wish to strike
the moon is obscured in deep gloom his
brother becomes bright red in color the
great one hidden for a long time in the
shadows will hold the blade in the
bloody wound
the king is troubled by the Queen's
reply ambassadors will fear for their
lives the greater of his brothers will
EE disguise his action two of them will
die through anger hatred and envy when
the great Queen sees herself conquered
she will show in excess of masculine
courage naked on horseback she will pass
over the river pursued by the sword she
will have outraged her faith earth
shaking fire from the centre of the
earth will cause tremors around the new
city two great rocks will war for a long
time then Arethusa will read on a new
river the divine wrath overtakes the
Great Prince a short while before he
will marry both supporters and credit
will suddenly diminish counsel he will
die because of the shaven heads those of
Loretto will be in the moss a kill all
those from the law and sin the seaside
track will come near the high valley
when the Spanish open every route
Bordeaux and potty air at the sound of
the bell will go with a great fleet as
fast as LAN gone a great rage will
search up against the French when a
hideous monster is born they're all gone
the gods will make it appear to mankind
that they are authors of a great war
before the sky was seen to be free of
weapons and rockets the greatest damage
will be inflicted on the left under one
man peace will be proclaimed everywhere
but not long after will be looting and
rebellion because of a refusal town land
and sea will be broached about a third
of a million dead or captured
the Italian lands near the mountains
will tremble a [ __ ] and the lion not
strongly United in place of fear they
will help each other
freedom alone moderates the French the
tyrants a limb will be put to death at
the harbour but Liberty will not be
regained however a new war arises from
vengeance and remorse a lady is honoured
through force of terror in front of a
monastery will be found a twin infant
from the illustrious and ancient line of
a monk his fame renown and power through
sex and speech is such that they will
say the living twin is deservedly chosen
a man will be charged with the
destruction of temples and sects altered
by fantasy he will harm the rocks rather
than their living ears filled with
ornate speeches that which neither
weapon nor flame could accomplished will
be achieved by a sweet speaking tongue
in Council sleeping in a dream the king
will see the enemy not in war or of
military blood the leader who will
conduct great numbers of people far from
their skies to foreign customs and
language 5000 will die in Crete and
Thessaly the leader fleeing in a
seagoing supply ship the great king will
join with two kings United in friendship
how the great household will sigh around
Narbonne
what pity for the children for a long
time a great bird will be seen in the
sky near Dole and the lands of Tuscany
he holds a flowering branch in his beak
but he dies too soon and the war ends
[Music]